Tom Brady already in the house the Derek
Jeter built in Tampa that's where Brady
is going to be living during his time
with the Buccaneers and spent a couple
of hours on Wednesday talking to the
great Howard Stern Peter we talked about
the looming Tom Brady Howard Stern
interview last week on this program and
they played a clip of it on Tuesday on
Stern show because Howard Stern and his
producer Rob and were were very confused
by the fact that the people in the
sports media actually cared and it's
like I'm confused that they're confused
because it's the greatest radio
interviewer of all time the greatest
quarterback of all time with a
reputation for saying absolutely nothing
something's got to give and what
ultimately gave was Tom Brady was more
candid more open more of more effusive
more descriptive more more human than
he's ever been there's two takeaways I
have from that I've never heard Tom
Brady talk publicly about his
relationship with his wife that was
revelatory the other part of it that I
thought was interesting is that because
this is just my opinion Mike okay
thought it was interesting to see him
come to the defense of Bill Belichick
and you know so many people in and
around Boston in the media in the
national media everything you know
basically said that you know there was a
major problem between Belichick and
Brady and Mike as I wrote at the time
okay this was not Bellatrix fault this
was not Brady's fault this was life okay
if you've done the same thing for two
decades and you want to do something
different
it doesn't mean you hate the guy who's
your boss it means that maybe you don't
love the guy but you truly appreciate
what he's meant to you in your career
and now you want to do something
different and have a different boss
that's what this means I will always
believe that Tom Brady the day that he
steps on the
you know on the stage in Canton Ohio in
2028 or whenever it is he goes into the
Hall of Fame that he will hug Bill
Belichick for 15 seconds and he'll mean
it so those are the two things that
really interested me and I thought was I
thought was very enlightening about his
time with Howard Stern I was very very
taken aback by his willingness to talk
publicly about the letter that his wife
gave him outlining yeah she's unhappy
with the relationship and that's why he
stopped being as involved in the OTAs
and but from her perspective when she
marries the guy she's not thinking he's
gonna play football until he's 45
she's assuming that the guys get out of
it by their late 30s and she didn't sign
on for this much time and this many
years being devoted to football and I
remember Peter after Super Bowl 51 when
Tom Brady came back from the 28 to 3
deficit the Patriots win she said this
is the perfect time to walk away and I
think she wasn't kidding about it and so
here we are three years removed from
that and and you have to get the right
balance and to me that was the most
refreshing aspect of it because we all
have those trade-offs in our
relationships with our spouses and you
know there's this this strange reality
this fairy tale that Tom and Giselle
seem to inhabit and it's kind of nice to
see that at the core it's no different
than what the rest of us deal with
there's a give-and-take there's a
balance and if it ever gets too far out
of balance the other half of the
partnership gets upset and says
something about it and that's okay
that's how you restore the balance you
know it's like I just you know sitting
home and and having to be at home for
the last month or whatever it is I've
you we've all been some shows and I've
been watching this show on Netflix
called the crown 30 episodes about the
life and times of Queen Elizabeth and
look I'm a little bit of a history nerd
not as much as a lot of people but I
really am and I was fascinated with it
and one of the things that really hits
home watching that and not necessarily
comparing it apples to apples to Brie
and Giselle but one of the things that
occurs to you is that there's there are
things done for public consumption and
then there's what's done behind the
scenes and I agree with you Mike that in
my opinion the the thing that really
kind of knocked the block off of me was
when he started talking about you know
that letter and his relationship with
his wife and his family I thought that
was really good really honest of him and
and I think it also shows you maybe
that's the reason everybody said man why
is Brady doing this why is he doing this
I mean he does have a high-powered
publicist who I'm sure had something to
do with it but I think in general I
think Tom Brady got a kick out of doing
that the other day did you hear anything
and I didn't listen to it all okay and I
listened to a lot of it you know after
it happened but did you didn't hear any
sound of him like hey can we hurry this
up I mean it was like he was on a
shrinks couch and the session went long
and and and he was fine with that you
know and so I I was I thought it was
refreshing I think your words right and
and that is a credit to what Howard
Stern has built over the years that he
has created the reputation where if you
agree to get on his couch you are going
to open up he doesn't have to try
anymore right you know by agreeing to do
it where this is going to lead and it
took a while to get him there but he got
there and he was more candid than he's
ever been in his entire life so like I
mean Howard Stern is absolutely the best
in the business when it comes to
interviewing even if it takes two hours
to crack that she'll it was worth it it
was a great conversation and I don't
know what more Tom Brady can ever say
now I think he said it all I think if he
never says another word I'd be fine with
it all right we've got more words you
know go ahead let me just say one last
thing the one thing he has to he can
talk a lot about is Tampa Bay it almost
seems like it was like he was forcing
Bruce Arians name into that conversation
you know it
all about kind of the past and and and
and all that so there's a lot of the
future I think that still to be written
with him
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports